Please welcome Beth Behrs.
(applause)
Hi Drew
Hi, how are you!?
I am so excited to meet you,
I'm such a big fan. I'm totally geeking out right now.
(laughs)
Oh my gosh!
You know, it's funny too cause when you came on the screen,
I was really inspired
by your like, hipster meets like,
Little House on the Prairie,
Laura Ashley locket like, tiered blouse vibes.
(giggles)
I mean, you said my dream word
which is Little House on the Prairie.
I basically belong in the 1800s, but I live here now,
but that kind of seems like the theme of COVID right?
Like everybody just has weird hobbies, like baking bread
and churning butter like they did in the 1800s, now.
Yeah, I was reading that like you learned to knit
with like Sally Field and Kat Dennings,
is this that, is that true?
That's so true. Well, Sally, I had to knit in a movie
that I was doing with Sally Field,
but Kat, had to teach me how to knit,
because I totally didn't know how.
And then I got to set and, got really nervous in a scene
with Sally Field and then Sally had to fix my scarf
every take because I messed up so bad
(giggles)
in each take knitting but
Oh my God Sally-
Knitting is one 1800s thing
that I, I can't pick up.
How fun to have Sally field help you do anything.
Right? And that Max Greenfield too was in that movie.
We were both like at the first day of rehearsal
it was just me, him and Sally.
And Max and I were like shaking.
I mean, we're both just so nervous to meet her,
but it ended up, obviously it ended up years later,
Max and I now play husband and wife.
So it was like the perfect, perfect first job
'cause there was so much pressure on it.
(chuckles)
Well, thank God
you guys had each other for support,
you know Max has actually been on this show.
And he was a really good sport,
because he put on all of this makeup.
Yeah, and then-
Oh my God. He's never looked better.
He was so awesome.
But he put the makeup on at the beginning of the interview,
and then we got to some sort of serious subjects,
and there he was with this crazy face of makeup
and I was like, "Gosh Max!"
"I probably should have waited till the end
of the interview to have you do the makeup."
He's like, "Yeah, probably"
But he was just, so cool.
What a nice
He's literally, the best TV husband.
So, I could not ask for a better group
the whole group of The Neighborhood.
I've been very lucky like you were saying with sitcoms.
I don't think I'm the good luck charm,
I just think I've just literally been
in the best environments, you know,
Kat Dennings, with 2 Broke Girls,
and now Max and the cast of The Neighborhood.
It's just been such a blessing,
and I just hope I get 10 more years
of great people on television.
It's funny too, 'cause I was reading
in your thing that you were working
as a nanny and a bartender when you got 2 Broke Girls.
Is that true?
Oh yeah. I was a broke girl, 7 days a week,
I was like working full time and actually,
(chuckles)
I, I didn't even own pair of high heels.
I went, I went to my audition
for Caroline Channing in cowboy boots.
So Michael Patrick King,
the amazing creator of 2 Broke Girls called me
for my final screen test and was like,
"Uh, do you own like,
not a Little House on the Prairie dress and like heels,
like could you wear something upper East side?"
And I was like, "Oh yeah, totally."
But I had no money cause I was a real broke girl.
So I went to Nordstrom, I kept all the tags on my clothes,
and the like label on the Steve Madden heels that I got.
And when he hugged me at my screen test,
he's like, "Are there tags all over your clothes?"
And I was like, "Well, yes, because if I don't get this job
I have to return all the clothes
(giggles)
I can't afford them"
So I was a total like cowgirl,
trying to pretend she was upper East side.
Well, I actually read
that you're a cowboy boot enthusiast,
so of course that's what you were wearing.
But that being said, I loved that detail
'cause I think there are a lot of aspiring people out there,
that it's nice to know that your life can change
and that you can follow those dreams
and they can be realized.
Absolutely. I mean, I had a-
I love that.
I was writing Funny or Die sketches,
and that's what Kat Dennings, Michael Patrick King
and Whitney Cummings saw that
got me the job on 2 Broke Girls.
And that was something I made on an iPhone, myself.
You know? So, yeah.
I'm speaking of iPhones,
I understand you have countless poems on your phone
and that you have put your poetry out into the world.
By the way, what do you think of Amanda Gorman?
I'm freaking out.
Oh my God
A Star Is Born.
I love her so, so much.
I met her.
We did a, we did a benefit at the Geffen Playhouse
here in LA with, for Dick Van Dyke.
And, and we were both at the event,
she was reading a poem she wrote for the Geffen
like a commission and I bonded with her right away.
And then to see her at the inauguration, it was like,
I'm fine, she's finally getting the, the due she deserves.
I mean, I'm no Amanda Gorman,
my poems are like nature birdie sing song
compared to like her changing the world.
But,
(chuckles)
but I am a huge,
huge fan of hers.
And I'm just so glad the world sees now
what I saw a few years ago.
You know,
I am just so excited to have gotten to talk with you today.
I've had the fortunate pleasure
of hanging out with Max, in full makeup.
(chuckles)
Kat Dennings is a friend of the show,
she's already been on twice. I'm just obsessed with her.
I can only imagine what 6 years,
and continued friendship with is like with that wonder,
(chuckles)
and you deserve the good groups,
you are in the good groups,
because you help make them the good groups.
Thank you Beth Behrs so much,
and The Neighborhood airs Mondays
at 8:00 PM Eastern and Pacific time on CBS.
(upbeat music)